welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's fantastic four film
was finally confirmed or released on
november 8th 2024 the launch of phase
six which means the mcu will have at
that point evolved past the phase five
earthbound stories of captain america
new world order daredevil born again and
thunderbolts and more toward the cosmic
landscape of avengers kang dynasty and
avengers secret wars details about a
director in the cast of fantastic four
are expected to come soon in d23 but for
now marvel head kevin feige confirmed
that this fantastic four film will not
be an origin story the hollywood
reporter wrote quote feige compared
marvel's new take on the heroes to its
pack with sony to bring spider-man in
the mcu noting this will not be another
origin story a lot of people know this
origin story a lot of people know the
basics how do we take that and bring
something that they've never seen before
said feige who added that given the
super team launched in the marvel comics
universe back in 1961 we've set a very
high bar for ourselves with bringing
that to the screen an interesting route
for feige to take because arguably
moviegoers knew about spider-man's
origin from the spider bite to uncle
ben's death and with great power yada
yada from two immensely popular films i
would not say general audiences hold the
2005 fantastic four film or the 2015
reboot as closely to their hearts in
fact many of us so to sit through that
2015 film never want to think about it
ever again but from everything we've
learned we can actually use this to
narrow down exactly why marvel studios
is giving them a new origin and what
that origin might look like so just to
explain the fantastic war's origin from
the marvel comics reed richards was a
child prodigy who gained several college
degrees by the time he was 18 until he
went to state college in new york where
he met victor von doom from latvia
victor hated read right away and says uh
anyone want to switch dorms with me and
reed richards end up with a roommate of
ben grimm also during his college years
reid met and fell in love with sue storm
during these years victor builds a
machine that fails because he refused to
listen to read actually later we learned
that ben graham sabotaged this machine
this is what damaged victor's face and
made him hate read forever and then
victor went on a trip abroad and learned
from tibetan monks how to gain some
mystical powers he forged his metal mask
took over liberia became doctor doom
meanwhile reed begins to build a
revolutionary starship for the military
that he co-funds with inheritance from
his father the government cuts the
funding though so reed rushes to a test
flight where he is joined by ben in
sioux and johnny storm hoping to find
another solar system but that ship
passes through a cosmic ray storm that
gives all four of these powers so at
this point they decide to band together
as a fantastic four marvel's first
family to fight alien threats and doctor
doom becomes their primary recurring foe
now until now our leading theories for
the mcu fantastic four film were that it
could be a period film set in the 1960s
a version of quantum media director
peyton reed's pitch to fox years ago
something that multiverse madness seemed
to reference fantastic work did you guys
chart in the 60s or now that we know
john watts is no longer directing this
fantastic four film some believe that
john krasinski could be positioned to
star in and direct this film as reed
richards and multiverse of madness
krasinski had a number of lines that
suggested a future for this character
from his definition of incursions ahead
of the secret wars event the larger the
footprint you leave behind the greater
the risk of an incursion
incursion an incursion occurs when the
boundary between two universes erodes
and they collide
destroying one
or both entirely two reed alluding to
his wife sue storm and their children
franklin and valeria richards i have
children of my own i understand your
pain is their mother still alive
yes
good there will be someone left to raise
them but then the scarlet witch dashed
our hopes that the 838 reed richards
himself could lead us into this future
but that doesn't mean john krasinski
couldn't return to play a variant of
reed from another universe one would
think if he was truly a one-and-done
cameo he and jimmy fallon wouldn't have
been so pressured to tiptoe around the
future fantastic four movie in a recent
episode of the tonight show comic-con
they just announced all these new movies
and they announced there's gonna be a
fantastic four movie yes you're not
allowed to say anything i'm not allowed
to really ask you you're right uh but
you think they don't tell you anything
they don't tell you anything no until
right before you're about to do it
that's right yeah and there's also a
rumor that uh your wife uh emily blunt
will play sue storm oh hey jimmy
i'm going to tell you on your show
oh my gosh someone killed him right now
can we get a medic actually later in
this segment when fallon jokes with
krasinski about an office fan theory
about jim halper being evil krasinski
says well they're on to me because i
played it as a super villain
that's why that's why i did fantastic
four to balance it out i had already
done the villain so
let's let's talk about uh uh super pets
uh no jimmy let's not talk about super
pets let's talk about what he just said
that's why i did fantastic four yeah i'm
reading too much into it i know
krasinsky was not saying that's why i
did fantastic for the film necessarily
they haven't even began shooting the
movie yet he was referring really to his
past work as reed richards cameo in the
multiverse madness movie but still
balance hesitation suggests that he was
cautioned by someone important not to
spend too much time speculating about
krasinski's possible future as reed
richards implying that there probably is
still some future at all because if
there wasn't a future i don't think they
would care that much about joking around
about it so fighting confirming that the
2024 fantastic four film will not be an
origin story suggests that we probably
won't be seeing the fantastic four in
the 1960s like i love the idea of a
period piece origin story in the style
of the first captain america film making
the fantastic board removed from their
original time period but it just does
not make sense to go to the 60s if this
movie is going to start with them in the
middle of their career in the mcu
present day but if that's the case then
marvel studios is gonna have to explain
where they have been and why we haven't
seen them in the mcu to this point like
sure marvel could justify peter parker
and black panther's absences by just
leaning on the secrecy of those
characters but the fantastic four do not
live in secret they are known for being
public superheroes with no secret
identities and celebrity status so how
does the mcu establish a fantastic
four's celebrity status in this universe
without showing their origin at this
point forward well when you eliminate
all those possibilities the mcu
fantastic form must be set in another
universe or across several universes as
part of an incursion event or
established at the fantastic four have
been off dimension in a place like the
negative zone the negative zone would
tie in neatly with the way ms marvel
introduced the bengals which we think
are based on captain marvel's mega bands
which transports one into the negative
zone that actually could be where kamala
khan is now actually in my exclusive
interview with iman valani she said that
the mystery of where the bengal takes
kamala in the marvels ties in with how
kamala was able to time travel did you
have questions for how the logic of this
time travel fits in with what we saw in
adventures end game or in loki
yup first thing i asked i'm like doesn't
this break all the rules and they're
like
oh
we'll figure that out
i think the marvel's is going to explain
it a little more to be fair
god i want to tell you things but this
is going to be on youtube
it's okay it's fine i understand it's
totally good i don't want to get you in
any trouble i i do think you know
god no i can't i can't in a year hey
please call me back so if the marbles is
set partly in the negative zone and
introduces the fantastic four there a
great villain for the mcu fantastic four
film could be annihilus who is an
insectoid conqueror who comes from the
negative zone seeking to extend his
lifespan with the cosmic control rod in
fact victor von doom could even start as
an anti-hero helping them in this fight
the way loki and mordo were comics
villains who were turned into
sympathetic allies at times in the films
but knowing that a fantastic four is the
start to phase 6 in the midst of the
multiverse saga steering toward kang
dynasty and secret wars both of those
titles coming out in the year that
follows fantastic four i think it is
inevitable that this film at least
touches on reed's relationship with his
future descendant nathaniel richards aka
kang this has to on some level be a
multiverse story and that's why i think
krasinski's been so cryptic when he's
asked about this since fantastic four is
not an origin story i think this film
has to show us the council of reeds a
gathering of reed richard variants from
across the multiverse one prominent
member of which could be played by john
krasinski but could also include joanne
griffith and miles teller so this
wouldn't necessarily mean krasinski is
the 616 reed richards they could totally
cast a new actor in that role but
krasinski would still be out there in
the multiverse we might even learn that
it was the council of reed's mistake of
overthinking the threat of their
descendants that created the kang crisis
to begin with reed's role in the
ancestry of kang could be why doom
becomes so eager to kill reed and sue in
the mcu to prune kang out of existence
this could be the genesis of their
conflict let me know what you think
about these theories for the fantastic
four's new origin in the mcu follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
me rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you